BILL LUAN: Shanghai GDG a very
interesting developer community.
SUSANNAH RAUB: I'm
glad somebody
has asked this question.
RETO MEIER: This is where
the magic happens.
JENNY MURPHY: This is primarily
a question and
answer show, so if any
of you out there
would like to ask questions.
IDO GREEN: Today in this GDL
episode, we speak a little bit
about the new Chromebook.
And then I would love to dive
more into new things that any
web developer should know about
Chrome Dev Tools and how
they could leverage them and be
more productive when they
are building their next web
app or mobile web app.
So without further ado, let's
start and try to go--
I have this short list of things
that we could go and
work on it together.
And here are the main ones.
Of course, as you can see,
it's a blog post that I'm
going to publish later today.
But for now, let's just
go and dive into it.
So the first thing that we have
today in Chrome-- and
basically, before we even start,
I would love to offer
web developers the opportunity
to install Chrome Canary
alongside their regular,
stable Chrome.
You could go and just Google
Chrome Canary, install it.
And when you're working on
your development, I would
extremely encourage
you to use it.
It will give you great
capabilities in terms of
having the greatest and latest
features in the Dev Tools.
And moreover, you could see how
Chrome is going to look
like in the next
6 or 12 weeks.
So the first thing that
we have today--
let's open Chrome
Dev Tools here--
is the opportunity to have
a device emulation.
So it's true that in the past
we had this opportunity with
other simulators that we
needed to install.
For instance, the iPhone
simulator on Mac or on any
iOS, and then for Android with
the simulators that work on
Windows, Mac, and
others platform.
But here, you have it
inside the browser.
So how you do that
is you saw--
or you didn't, but I'll
make it a bit bigger
so it will be easier.
I opened the Chrome Dev Tools.
Let me do this a big
bigger as well.
OK, so I'm going here to this
button, clicking on it.
And now when I have the Setting
opportunity, what I
can do here is basically
override the functionalities.
The main functionality
that I could
override is the user agent.
And that just allows me pretty
easily to mimic any mobile
device that I wish to do
or different browser.
It's very, very convenient and
efficient to see how your site
or web app will look on, let's
say, Android 2.3 or
BlackBerry, and so on.
So that's the first thing.
The other thing that is very
cool is the device metric.
You could now basically enter
any device metric that you
want to check.
But even more cool than that--
and you saw here, of course,
that it's just changing.
If you're overriding the
user agent, it will
automatically fit it.
So if I'm working now on iPhone
5, you could see that
it filled for me the
device metric.
And that's a great thing because
it's just letting you
work with the exact device
that you wish and get the
exact screen resolution
that you have there.
So that's one very cool feature
that we have today.
And basically, there's
a ton of other
features in the settings.
So if you want to drill down it
and see exactly what you're
getting there, this
in the new view.
Another very important thing
is to emulate Touch Event.
So if I'm clicking this
checkbox, from now on, I'll
get Touch Event.
And specifically for mobile
applications, this is very,
very crucial.
So we don't need to use what
we used in the past, like
listening to an extra event and
then have the ability to
have Click Event and
Touch Event.
Here what we're doing is
pretty straightforward.
We're just emulating
Touch Event.
And from now on, our regular
Chrome in our desktop
environment will act and will
fire those touch events.
So that's another pretty
cool new add-in.
Other things that we have in
Chrome Dev Tools are actually
under the Experiments.
And the experiments flag could
be triggered on by just going
to Chrome Flags.
Let me open it and just
show it to you.
So here, basically, you're
seeing all the different
experiments that you could
do today under Chrome.
The list is very long,
as you can see.
And what I really like in it is
that if you search just for
Dev Tools--
tools, yeah--
so enable Developer Tools
Experiments--
and in my case, it's
already enabled--
you could see things--
sorry, it's not enabled.
Let me enable it.
Or even better, yeah.
Let me enable it here.
OK.
And now if I go here
and reload it--
Yeah, basically I need
to restart Chrome.
Let me just get Chrome
restarted, the Chrome that I'm
using, and I'll open it again.
And then you'll be able to see
what did the flag that I
opened in the experiment.
Basically, we get another
tab under the Dev Tools.
And this tab will be all the new
experiments that you could
do, all the different features
that you want
to use will be there.
So let me just show
this to you.
Yeah, this is the wrong
program now.
And here we go.
OK.
Let's take this one.
And I'm opening it.
Yeah, so let's do another
new screen share.
And yes.
So now, basically what
you can see here--
and let me try just to
make it even larger.
OK, so you see here, I how
have a new tab called
Experiment.
And these experiments could give
you the new things that
are going to be baked in Chrome,
hopefully in that
feature, and in that form and
shape, maybe a bit differently
in the future.
But at least you could play
with them now and see
how they look like.
Show CPU activity and timelines,
or override the
device geolocation, orientation,
support SASS,
lots of very, very
cool things.
The Snippets support is one of
the things that I really like.
And you could actually drive
into JSON objects and see them
in a very nice format in
the console today.
So that's something that
we should open.
And another very important thing
that I see more and more
web developers are using these
days is the ability
to disable the cache.
So if you are working now, you
definitely don't want to be
miserable and try to figure
out if it's a
cache resource or not.
Probably at the beginning
of your development, the
prototyping, you want just to
make sure that the cache is
disabled, and each and every
time that you're hitting the
server, you're getting
the latest version.
Just check this option,
and you are a good.
Other cool things that
you could do here is
enable source map.
Source map is the option
to work with the
original form of the file.
So let's say that you have
in your build system a
notification for
your JavaScript
or some other phase.
Let's say, if you're working
with Dart and you have it
compiled to JavaScript,
basically with source map, you
could debug with the
original code base.
And that's, of course, extremely
useful, specifically
when you're working in those
cases that you don't want to
work with a code that's
been magnified.
You just want to work with
the source of it.
What other cool things
that I worked?
The ability to log
XHR is very nice.
And just to see the shadow dome
in places that you're
working with them is also
a very nice thing.
In terms of rendering, to show
the repaint rectangulars, it's
very nice just to have this
organization what's going on
with your site in terms
of rendering.
That's basically most of the
things that I wanted to dig
from Dev Tools inside
the settings.
Another other great capability
that had been covered in last
Google I/O was the ability how
to debug mobile websites.
Let me just show you where
you could find it.
So, yeah.
Let's close this one.
In the blog post that I'm going
to launch very soon, you
have here, basically, a great
talk by Pavel and Sam about
Dev Tools and how they allow you
to debug and be efficient
when you're working on
your mobile web apps.
That's something that I highly
encourage you to check out
I think we are in a quite
good timing so far.
I really apologize for
the people that were
here exactly at 2:00.
I had a bit of problems with
installing the new plug-in.
And that's why I couldn't
do it on air on time.
But I promise that the next
episode up here will be at
exactly 2:00 and not
2-0-something.
So until next time, thank
you very much.
And as always, if you have any
questions or feedback, just
feel free to reach
out to me on G+.
Just google greenido.
Or if you want, on Twitter,
greenido is one word as well.
And if you have a cool start-up
that you want to show
cast in this episode, just feel
free to reach out to me.
I'll share show notes for these
episodes on my blog.
And I'll put a link there
for people that want
to be on the show.
Just fill a short form, and
then we'll contact you.
We have quite a lot of very
interesting episodes that
we're going to run in
the next few weeks.
Some of them will be based on
great people that I met
yesterday in DLD Tel Aviv.
It's a big, big Yossi Vardi
festival and lots of great
VCs, NGOs, and developers
were there.
We had two amazing events--
Google for Women
Entrepreneurship 2.0, and the
other was what Android can do.
And for people in Israel that
are not part of the GDG, I
highly encourage you
to check it out.
They are almost biweekly
or monthly meetings.
And in most of them, you have
great speakers, great content.
And you're just meeting very
cool people that are all
passionate about Android,
Chrome, HTML5, and what's cool
on the web with or without
Google platforms.
So just feel free to
hang out with us.
And thank you very much.
Bye-bye.